The clinic store carries a supplement called trace mineral drops by concerned trace. Are these drops okay to take regularly? Okay, so understand some things in our store are not necessarily things that I would recommend. I am never recommended the trace mineral drops to anybody.
So I didn't recommend them to the person who asked this question. So why? Well, I want to take a liquid mineral. Why can't I take this?
Because all these liquid minerals are key-lated in correct way. They are elemental minerals. So let me finish a question. Are the drops okay to take regularly if diagnosed with Hodgicoids in the pulmonary cancer? Is the ingredient lithium okay?
So lithium is typically okay in a mineral supplement. My struggle with the liquid minerals is that they are all the liquid minerals that I have ever seen are elemental minerals.
The only reason why we carry them in our stores because we've had demand for non-patients asking for them. So we carry them in our store that our supplier has them so that we ended up putting them on our store. I don't recommend people taking these and I may actually have record put on this. I may not have it on this listing but on the other liquid mineral listings.
I put on the listing that says Dr. Cutts says Dr. Cutts doesn't recommend these minerals and I put down what I recommend. I don't think we should be consuming elemental minerals than are from the first. Now there's there's the reason is is that we're not supposed to be dirt. We're supposed to eat plants. That's what we get our minerals from our plants and animals.
But when an animal okay let's say a cow is eating grass. The cow is getting the minerals from the grass in a in a form that's different than the soil. The cow doesn't eat dirt. The cow is eating grass. It is getting the mineral that's key-lated.
And a plant takes a mineral out of the soil and key-lates it in a double bond to an amino acid and then we eat a mineral that's key-lated in a double bond to an amino acid. These trace minerals that are liquid minerals are earth minerals. They're not key-lated correctly and they're not a good form of minerals.
Long story short, don't use the trace minerals. Use the clear multi-min that we have private label. That's the best mineral out there is lithium okay for anybody. Yes, the team is okay.
But minerals are okay for lymphoma patients just fine but make sure you get them in the right form which is the correctly key-lated form which is the aloea minerals which is the clear multi-min.